you are in a very difficult and
uncomfortable position
because I think leadership is more
difficult now than it has ever been
because you're dealing with you're
dealing with human anxiety you're
dealing with human uncertainty you're
dealing with human ambition and human
Egos and and again especially young
people who think they know what they
want and don't who have certainty and
are very outspoken and do not mind going
around their boss's boss to come to you
you know so you're going to be dealing
with a 19 year old saying why am I not
given this and you're like I don't where
are where do you work you know
[Music]
um
uh they have no fear
of doing that they also have no fear of
quitting
and so we've seen this pattern where
remember they're very they're as a Young
Generation they're actually less
equipped to deal with stress than
previous generations
uh and and so anxiety is high and
they're very confrontation avoidant
so for example we've seen this where
they feel like they deserve a raise
and they don't know how to ask for a
raise
and so instead of asking for raise
they'll just quit
and then sometimes with an email that
says you don't value me you don't pay me
enough you're like you just had to we
just had to ask the answer we love you
you know
so they're not afraid of quitting but
they are afraid of asking for things or
if they do ask for things that sometimes
crumbs across very aggressive or
accidentally black and white like I've
been here
um eight months and I would like a 50
raise
and I'm not exaggerating I mean you've
you know and and uh and the problem is
that they're ill-equipped what they're
doing is they're they're putting you in
a yes or no position
so even if you say here's the plan to
get you that over the course of the next
eight months
hey they take it as a no
because I asked for something black and
white and so one of the things I think
there's a huge opportunity for a company
is to help people to build in training
that helps them uh with their human
skills I hate the term soft skills
please let's never use that term again
you know we talk about hard skills and
soft skills those things are opposite
hard and soft are opposites their hard
skills the skills you need to do your
job and human skills the skills you need
to be a better human being and we want
you to excel at both and we're going to
train you to do both
and some of the human skills that are
underappreciated and under trained in
this day and age
are how to have difficult conversations
had of an effective confrontation how to
give and receive feedback
and I think we have to train those
things so that if we equip them with the
skills instead of saying I've been here
for eight months I want to raise to say
I've been here for eight months I really
love it here my goal is to stay here
I have
um Financial Ambitions can you help me
get on a path to get to this number now
we can have a conversation because it's
now a Continuum rather than a black and
white question but the point is is I
don't fault them they'd lack the skills
and so I think there's a huge
opportunity for an organization like
yours to teach these young people coping
mechanisms stress relief the biggest one
being how to ask for help that is the
single biggest thing that is lacking at
every generation
which is I am struggling can you help me
whether it's personal or professional
that is absolutely lacking and so we do
unhealthy things to help compensate
social media and other things